[Applause]
thank you very
can you hear me
good that's a start um I'm gonna stand
up do you mind
even when I'm sitting down I'm roughly
the same height so it doesn't make a
great deal of difference though that was
part of the introduction thank you I I'm
afraid I'm going to have to shoot off to
catch a train at ten to two and if I
don't get it I'm in trouble so if we end
a bit abruptly my apologies because I
like to talk as well that's the other
problem now let's start here you know
the problem about China is this is going
to absolutely change the world
and we are in this country and in our
continent phenomenally ignorant about it
worse than most of the rest of the world
I have to say now these are Gorman Sachs
figures in 2005 and what do you need to
know 2025 the Chinese economy is almost
the same size as the American economy at
the moment is just over one third of the
size 2050 which is obviously somewhere
ahead but you know you've got to take
these figures seriously China will be
almost twice the size of the United
States India the same size as China and
what these figures show us is the
extraordinary speed with which the world
is changing which we do not grasp and
the reason it's changing so quickly is
because
one China's got a population of 1.3
billion and secondly because it is
growing at roughly 10% a year and has
been for 30 years and the difficulty we
have is even knowing vaguely that what
this is what is happening in the world
and we are operating sort of in a
different time zone in terms of our
understanding of this so this is the
first problem we're just behind the
times the second problem I think is more
serious in a way and that is how to
understand China how to make sense of it
there is an overwhelming assumption in
the West certainly in this country that
China
somehow or other will end up like us
that we're really the only show in town
that there is only one form of modernity
and it is a Western modernity now this
is very arrogant and also very ignorant
because the assumption is that as
countries like China and India and
wherever you want to mention outside the
West change modernize the assumption is
that the process of modernization is
purely a question of markets competition
technology but it's not the process of
modernization is shaped equally by
history and culture and anyone who knows
anything about China knows that this is
a profoundly different society with a
fascinating and deep history now mainly
what I want to talk about tonight is
China as difference because until we get
that clear in our minds we can't make
sense of China we just keep getting it
wrong do you know the consistency with
which Western experts
get China wrong is extraordinary he's
absolute straw Denis virtually every you
know some latest person talks about
economic breakdown or political
breakdown it hasn't happened and it is
not going to happen in that simplistic
kind of way that people talk about now
there are four key concepts that I as
building blocks to understand China I
want to talk about there are other ones
as well but these are the ones I want to
talk about this is the first China's a
nation state well at least it's called
itself a nation state for about a
hundred years since the end of the
nineteenth century
now of course anyone who knows anything
about China knows that it's not a
hundred years old I mean in terms of a
continuing continuously existing
relatively centralized polity it starts
roughly here although the Chinese will
talk about five thousand years of
history but 221 BC the victory of the
Qin Dynasty the creation of the Qin
Empire and you can already see it
beginning to occupy the frontiers of
modern China in terms of this part of
China the eastern part of China where
the vast majority of people live this
side was a much later conquest by the
Ching dynasty in the 17th century where
which is very very lightly populated and
includes of course Xin Jiang and Tibet
no it only lasted thirteen years this
Tennessean was succeeded by the Han
still over two thousand years ago I know
you can see very clearly the the Han
Empire is not that far short of modern
central and eastern China and the
important thing then is that China is
only recently and marginally a
nation-state for two thousand years it
wasn't a nation-state
it was essentially a civilization state
and the Chinese sense of who they are of
what China is of what it means to be
Chinese is not derived from the last
hundred years of being a nation-state it
is derived from that sense of
civilizational identity what am I
talking about
Confucian values very very unusual
conception of the state in its
relationship to society likewise very
unique concept of the family or very
unusual concept to the family customs
like guanxi of course an idio graphic
language where you have a common a
common basis a common script but many
different languages operating to the
same written language so China's sense
of what it is is a civilizational sense
not a national sense this is so
different from the West
I mean basically for the United States
the conception of what America is of
course is 100 percent virtually
virtually wholly a function of being a
nation state and the nation-state period
for Europe it's not so total but by and
large for Britain for France for Germany
and so on their conception of what they
are and who they are for us is a
function of a nation-state period and
this is not true in the Chinese case so
when I talk about China being a
civilization state what do I mean three
elements one that it has this
extraordinary longevity secondly very
unusually there's a current science of
state as polity and the civilizational
the civilizational history and
civilizational roots and the third
element
sorry
[Music]
Oh
ah ah we have the progress now here we
have the third element okay of China
being a civilization strike this is a
huge country both demographically and
geographically these four provinces here
have between them color blue have a
population larger than that of the
United States the nine provinces covered
by the green or blue have a population
larger than that of or as large as that
as France or the UK in terms of
geographical size more or less the same
as the United States four times the
population of the United States and
great diversity in terms of living sense
and of course it's a much more diverse
country than Europe is a continent in
fact and that diversity is both socio
economic cultural and also political we
tend to think of China as somehow being
highly centralized partly associated
with the Communist period partly
associated with what is compared with
India for example a very strong sense of
Chinese identity but we should never
allow this to lead us to a view that
china is monolithic or homogenous it is
not it is not